okay good morning um so we are doing
Augustine today and um even though
Augustine is not as famous as some other
um thinkers we've looked at this
semester he's actually very important
because he's actually the intellectual
architect of the Catholic church and in
this world the Catholic church is the
largest organization it has 1.5
billion um
members it's been around for almost
2,000
years so and Augustine really is the
individual who
conceptualized the idea of the Catholic
church so for us to understand what the
Catholic church is and why it's endured
for so long I want to introduce a new
idea to to you call the end of
History this is a concept that was
introduced by American State Department
official named Francis fukayama at the
end of the Cold War when the Berlin W
Berlin Wall fell and his argument is
that history has been a struggle of
ideology we've had paganism we've had
communism we've had socialism we had
democracy and through this dialectic
through this constant struggle of ideas
we have now reached the end of History
where liberal consumer democracy is the
best idea not only is it the best idea
but it's the perfect idea that will
allow us to endure for the rest of
History therefore it is the end of
history now of course we we know this
idea is wrong what's in but what's
interesting for us is this has been a
recurring theme in human history where
every major political leader who's come
to power has announced
that this is the end of history that all
of history has led to this point where I
am now ruler and from now on we can
enjoy Paradise on uh Earth okay so let's
look at some examples that we looked at
this semester first example is King
David right remember that we discussed
that when King David came into Power he
sponsored the wunning of the Bible as an
apology to explain why he's King and we
ALS Al looked at the story constructed
by the Yahweh how Yahweh the god um he
builds the world because he's a poet
because he's
lonely and his history is a journey of
Yahweh trying to find a good friend that
could accompany him for eternity and it
turns out eventually he finds David and
so when he finds David he anoints the
House of David as the permanent rulers
of our world okay so that's the Bible
but then you you have um
Augustus who sponsored the writing of
the
inad and remember the inad it's really
the Journey of the troan heral in is as
he leaves Troy and he is um destined by
the gods to found the city of Rome and
the Roman
Empire and why does he do this because
eventually Rome will become the greatest
Empire on Earth with Augustus as the
first emperor and so that's the end of
History once the Roman Empire is
constructed then peace Eternal peace is
now um is now on Earth okay and then you
had
Constantine who um was Emperor after he
fought a brutal Civil War to reunite the
Roman Empire and once he rebuilt the
Roman Empire he converted to
Christianity and um he organized in 325
the Council of nessia where they agreed
to introduce the idea of the godhead
remember we discussed last class how
they idea the godhead it marks a major
intellectual revolution in human history
it's the beginning of monotheism it's
the idea that God is both everything and
nothing which is also Al the idea of
Empire
okay
um there's also a major civil war after
cone dies another Roman Emperor feel
dois comes to the throne and in 380 he
issu something called the idct of fonica
which established Christianity as the
official
religion of the Roman Empire and when he
does that they begin to root
um paganism and other
um um uh religions and at this point we
can also think this is the end of
History we've discovered Christianity
which will make um Paradise on Earth the
problem though of course is that in
410 Rome is
sacked and this is a problem this
creates something called a crisis of
Faith why because
a lot of people believe that Rome was
sacked by The Barbarians by the vovs
precisely because Rome converted to
Christianity before Rome was a pagan
society and they believe that by
converting to Christianity two things
happened the first thing happened was
the old Gods uh
Jupiter and uh the others became furious
at the Romans and were determined to
punish the Romans by sending the
Barbarian Ians okay also they believe
that Christianity it's a religion of
slaves it teaches us to be merciful and
kind and compassionate but that's not
the way the world works okay so now you
have a crisis of faith and the Very
authority of the Catholic church is
challenged and so at this point a a
Augustine who is a bishop of the
Catholic church in Northern Africa he
comes up with this theory that
establishes the Catholic Church as
beyond the world okay so other
individuals have introduced the idea of
end of history but what atin does is he
takes the Catholic church out of History
okay out of
History what does that mean it means
that history is really about Mortals
battling for power but the Catholic
Church it is a representative of God on
Earth therefore it will remove itself
from history you guys can battle it out
but we will always be the representative
of God on Earth okay and to establish
this he writes a book called city of God
he and he talks about two cities you
have
Rome which is the Earthly City it's a
city of power and
greed and the sou and then you have a
city called Jerusalem which is the
spiritual City
it is the city of the of God of spirit
of selflessness of
paradise okay and the Catholic Church
will always be centered in Jerusalem and
if you follow the Catholic church if
you're obedient to God then your spirit
can also enter Jerusalem otherwise
you'll always be trapped in
Rome okay
what he also does that's very important
is by establishing his theory he solves
a major problem for uh political leaders
remember before um David Augustine
Constantine whenever they came into
power they faced three major problems
the first is legitimacy why are you the
king the second is cultural cohesion how
do you un the people behind a common
ideology
the third problem was cultural
differentiation why are you different
from other people okay and what the
Catholic church under Augustine proposes
is we'll solve all three problems for
you we the Catholic Church will give you
legitimacy because you are the
representative of God on Earth okay and
that's why even though
um in next in the following few
centuries there will always be power
shifts the Catholic Church will always
be at the center of these power shifts
because they are the ones who are able
to provide Authority and legitimacy
whoever comes into Power like for
example
Charlamagne okay so that's what um
Augustine is
proposing so today what I want to look
at um are some of augustin's writings to
see what is the ideology or doctrine
that underlines the Catholic church this
is important for us because it is
Augustine's ideology that will drive
European history for the next thousand
years in fact I will make the argument
to you today that it is his
ideology that
will um Mark the coming of the Dark Ages
in Europe 500 years when um Society
lacked social
Innovation and um you weren't allowed to
criticize
Authority
okay so that's the argument to you uh
today I'll sit over here and oh oh thank
you okay all all right yeah
sorry
yeah this is why I don't use computers
okay yeah yeah it's it's fine okay all
right so we are going to look at two
major works of um Augustine the first is
confessions and confessions is very
famous it's something that uh most
people have heard of
um and it's really the biography
autobiography of um Augustine and in
fact it's considered the first authentic
autobiography in the
world and in the story he he talks about
his life where he grows up with a pagan
father and um a Christian mother Nam
Monica and in the beginning he is a very
disobedient young man he refuses to
follow the wishes of his mother and
refuses Christianity and he goes on a
long
journey of youthful sin okay he um has a
mistress who he doesn't marry he
explores uh heresies like neoplatonism
and manism but then one day he has a
what we call a Damascus moment right God
speaks to him and says Augustine open
the B
he opens the Bible and starts his
religious journey and in age
42 um Augustine becomes the uh Bishop of
hippo and from then he begins to
construct the ideology that will
underpin the Catholic
Church okay now um for whatever reason
historians think this
Memoir is authentic or he's telling the
truth truth and the one thing that you
will learn in life is whenever a
politician or a power individual writes
a memoir it's complete BS okay there's
something authentic or true about it so
we're going to read a bit of confessions
and this is really the most famous part
of the confessions it's really
Augustine's rewriting of the story of
The Garden of um Eden okay so this this
is this is what he says when he's Young
a young man or a young boy I wanted to
carry out an act of theft and did so
driven by no kind of need other than my
inner lack of any sense of or feeling
for justice okay so one thing that he
that he points out over and over again
is we are born in sin we are of sin we
are evil people okay and that's why the
Catholic church is
important because only the Catholic
Church can steer us into goodness if
left to our own devices we can only
commit sin and this starts from the womb
okay we are born in sin we are born of
sin I sawo something which I had in
plenty of much better quality my desire
was not to enjoy not what I sought by
stealing but merely excitement of
thieving and the doing of what was wrong
okay what do we sin because we enjoy
sinning because that is our nature when
we steal it is not because we're hungry
or because we need something it's
because we enjoy
stealing okay it's pure pleasure there's
a pure Tree near a Vineyard Laden with
fruit though attractive in neither color
nor taste okay so again this is the
retelling of the garden of of Eden where
there's a tree of knowledge right well
here there's a peer tree okay to shake
the tree the fruit of the tree and car
off the peers I and a gang of naughty
adolescents set off late at night after
we had continued our game in the streets
we carried off a huge load of peers okay
so they stole a huge load of peers from
someone he doesn't tell us who but it's
someone okay and
then they didn't eat the any of the
peers they just gave it to
pigs okay they just did this because
they enjoyed
sinning now okay let me make a few
comments first of
all we would think this it's just boys
having fun right they don't mean any
harmed by this they're just playing
they're just being curious they just
exploring which is part of human nature
right what all is saying is that's
exactly the problem curiosity can only
lead to evil exploration can only lead
to sin
that's why we commit sin because we
think curiosity is a good thing when in
fact it's an evil thing that can will
harm that can only harm
others
okay
and the other thing is this is this is
clearly a
retelling of the Garden of Eden story
right where Adam and Eve they um eat
that fruit and here what Augustine is
saying
is first of all Adam and Eve are
stealing okay that that is not stealing
is not a word used in the Bible okay but
atin is saying they are stealing that's
the first thing second thing
is Augustine is saying that the stealing
was intentional they knew what what they
were doing was wrong
but they did it because it felt
good okay so this is a radical
reconceptualization of the idea of
original sin remember Paul um introduced
the idea of original sin to us where why
did Jesus have to come to redeem us
because we disobeyed God In The Garden
of edpt it was a mistake and Jesus had
to pay ransom for that mistake okay that
was Paul's argument what Austin is
saying um is something radically
different he's saying that first of
all um we didn't make a make a mistake
we are the
mistake all right we are the ones born
to sin therefore we were always
disobeyed and then what else he what
else he but what else he's saying is
this and this is really important this
happens in about 350
right this is about 300 years after
Jesus sacrificed himself for us and he's
still
sinning so he is negating the sacrifice
of Jesus just because Jesus sacrificed
himself does not mean we've stopped
sinning in fact we continue to
sin
okay
so this is a
radical
reconceptualization of the Christian
faith we are born Sinners and we will
always sin unless we are taught to obey
God that is our fundamental mission on
Earth to obey God
okay okay
so let's go to the city of God now and
again the city of God becomes the inal
AR uh blueprint for the building of the
Catholic church and one thing that he
talks a lot about in the city of God is
that of rape and so what's happening um
throughout this time and what was very
common is if a woman were raped out of
wedlock or if a if a woman were raped by
her husband what they will often do is
kill themselves why because the
Christian faith taught them that
Chastity was very important okay and if
you're the Empire this is a problem for
you right because you can't have women
killing themselves because of rape rape
happens all the time if women kill
themselves eventually you're going to
have an a population implosion okay so
actually what Augustin will do is spend
a lot of time explaining why rape
is um why rape is not a bad
thing okay so to do so he talks about Lu
lucrecia lucrecia remember who Luccia is
Lucia
um we we discussed Luca when we
discussed the history of the RO Roman
Republic uh at first Rome was a uh
monarchy and the
king the King's son he he was a sinful
person and he liked to rape uh other
woman he he he lik to rape woman and
lucrecia was was famous in Rome for her
Chastity for her virtue so he thought
it'd be fun to rape her after she was
raped she called her husband and her
husband's best friend named Lucius junus
Buddhas together and she she made them
swear that they will avenge her
dishonoring and they did and they make
sure that she they would follow out on
this she took out a knife and she
stabbed herself in the heart killing
herself and this marks the beginning of
the Roman Republic so in the eyes of
Romans her death her suicide is what
gave birth to the Roman Republic so
she's honored and considered a hero by
the Roman people and what Augustine will
say is no she's not a hero because she
killed herself not
for the good of Rome but for her own
vanity for her own
Pride for the fact that she lost faith
she was
embarrassed she didn't have the glory of
being considered the most chased and
virtuous woman in Rome and that's why
she killed herself and this is pride
this is arrogance this is ego which goes
against the will of God okay so let's
let's look at very quickly what what he
saying what he saying her killing of
herself or suicide because although not
adulterous she had suffered an
adulterous Embraces was due to the
weakness of Shame okay the weakness of
Shame she died because she felt
ashamed not to the high value she set on
chass she was ashamed of another's foul
deed committed on her even though not
with her as a Roman woman excessively
eager honor okay Pride that's what
killed her her
Pride sorry let me
um I hate
computers
okay but Christian women do not kill
themselves if you are a true Christian
you do not you would never kill yourself
why because murder is a worse crime than
rape also rape is something that happens
in the
mind it's not
real Christian women do not kill
themselves they have the glory of
Chasity within them the testimony of
their conscience they have this in the
sight of God if you were raped but you
didn't you not consent to it don't worry
because God knows and and so God will
forgive but if you kill
yourself that's
committing wrong against God okay so
this argument um I mean it's really
gaslighting okay and he does this a lot
in his
um in his thing in in his logic okay
he's really gaslighting he's making
certain points about the nature of
humans okay first of all we each and
every one of us is God's Property we are
not free of oursel we are God's Property
therefore when we cure ourselves we are
offending God okay that's the first
thing second thing that he's saying is
we can do no good because we are
burdened by our pride and our sin if we
choose to act we can only do wrong okay
so what he's saying is this if you are
walking in the forest and you see a
young boy drowning in the lake don't
jump in the lake to save him because one
you might die and two everything is
controlled by God therefore everything
has an intention so when you jump and
save the boy you might be interfering in
God's
plan therefore the only solution to
Salvation how do you make yourself good
in the eyes of God don't don't do
anything God knows everything God has a
plan just obbey the will of God and the
will of God means doing nothing and in
fact doing nothing is the best thing you
can do because if you are born of sin
and you're only capable of sin when you
do nothing you are doing good in the
world okay so again this is
gaslighting but this becomes the
doctrine of the Catholic church and it
begins what we call the Dark Ages
because it forces people and most people
want salvation most people want to be
good in the eyes of God it forces people
to be passive and
obedient and unable to question and
explore okay so any questions so far
before I move on
okay let's look at another line from the
seity of God thus when men lives by the
standard of men and not by the standard
of God he is like the devil right think
about this when you choose to follow
your nature you are like the
devil it is only by negating yourself it
is only by denying yourself can you be
good all right if you trust your
instincts if you trust your intuition if
you use your imagination you are like
the devil okay this is exactly what he's
saying with this sentence the other
thing that he does is he's very
repetitive so he'll keep on going like
this for a very long
time all right I mean this is all just
reputation even an angel should not have
lived by the angel standard but by gods
so I should stand firm in the truth and
speak the truth that comes from God's
truth not the lie that deres from his
own falsehood okay even angels must live
by God standard so only God has the
power to
choose we can choose but we can only do
evil so we should not
choose
okay so this is a so so the thing about
August that's very important for us to
understand is he studied
rhetoric and so he's very good at
gaslighting okay so twisting things in
order to force your
compliance all right so he says when men
lives by the standard of Truth he lives
not by his own standard but by God's
he's just repeating himself same
sentence but he just repeats himself
over and
over okay so why is he doing
this why is he doing this and any
thoughts what the city of God the city
of God we Sorry S I could turn the
question back to you yeah the like the
one thing I'm curious about like both of
the confessions and the City of God yeah
is
that at this point like who is his
audience who is he writing for that's a
great question that that that's exactly
it who is his audience exactly his
audience is clearly not
for us or Ordinary People because at
this time most people don't read and
write right so his audience is actually
for the priesthood okay his audience are
for those individuals who are about to
be anointed by the Catholic Church to
preach to the
Layman and as a priest you are uh forced
to encounter a lot of theological issues
right and so what atin is doing when
writing Citi of God and confessions is
creating a rhetorical manual for the
priests to basically Gaslight their
constituencies does that make sense okay
so think of this in many ways as the
equivalent of the confusion class
in China right so um when when you apply
to become a bureaucrat in China you have
to take the confusion examinations right
and how do you pass examinations by
memorizing this
crap right and if you look at it uh if
you think about it
rhetorically if you think think about
the underlying theories it's really the
same thing okay the emperor is always
right just do what the emperor
wants right so this is this is in many
ways it's all it is is a rhetorical
manual that priests have to memorize if
they are to become anointed by the
church right and once you memorize this
then
whatever problems that you may encounter
you can just recite from this manual
right and the main argument is hey we're
born of sin therefore you can do no good
even by asking questions you are
exposing the devil in yourself right
even by questioning the
church by asking me this question you're
showing the devil in
you and our responsibility the only path
the only path salvation in this world is
by fighting the devil within
us okay so Focus your attention on the
Devil Within you ignore the fact that
the world is corrupt and evil you know
you know the fact that the
landlord is uh exploiting you you know
the fact that the Catholic church is
stealing from you okay ignore that that
doesn't matter what matters is the
internal World in you life is a constant
struggle against sin because the devil
is in you and you must purchas the devil
if you are to find
Salvation uh in God okay so that's the
logic of the
argument any questions
okay are are we are we clear about this
okay it's not a sophisticated argument
but it's a clever argument that becomes
the basis for the dominance of Catholic
Church during the Dark Ages in the
Middle
Ages right all right now what he's going
to do and this is very important is he's
going to analyze the story of Adam and
Eve okay he's going to explore why did
this happen why did Adam and Eve in
Paradise why did they disobey God all
right so let's let's look at this
logic it was in secret that the first
human beings began to be evil and the
result was that they slipped into open
Disobedience okay what this is saying
is why why did they disobey because Eve
and Adam conspired in secret against God
does that make sense okay that's what
he's saying here it was in secret okay
they conspired that the first human
beings and and Eve began to be evil it
was because they talked to each other
that they conspired to disobey
God all
right for they would not have arrived at
the evil act if an evil will had not
preceded it why did they do this evil
act because they themselves were
Evil all right that's important to
understand they were not tricked by the
serpent they were not curious they were
just
evil for pride is started every kind of
sin and what is pride except long for a
perverse kind of of exaltation okay they
want to become God the serent told them
that if you ate this ate the fruit you
become God that's what Ted them okay the
pride for it is a perverse kind of
exaltation to abandon the basis on which
the Mind should be firmly fixed and to
become as it were based on oneself and
so remain what this is saying is pride
means we are Le in God and becoming more
of ourselves okay there's two ways you
can go you can move towards God which
means to obey God or you can move
towards
yourself okay which is to
sin this happens when a man is too
pleased with himself and a man is
self-complacent when he deserts that
changes good in which rather than him in
himself he ought to have found his
satisfaction Pride okay Pride makes us
happy makes us ambitious but it will
blind us from
God this desision is voluntary for if
the will had been made unshaken its love
of the higher changes good which shed on
it light to see and Kindle in it fire to
love it would not have been diverted
from this love to follow its own
pleasure okay we abandon God and the
will would not have been so darkened in
chill in consequence as that the woman
belied that the serpent had spoken the
truth the man to put his wife's will
above God's commandment okay so here's
the
problem the man listened to the woman
Adam was tricked by
Eve all
right and suppose that this was a venal
transation when he refused to deser his
life's companion even though they refus
to entail companionship in sin okay so
Adam was forced to make a decision Eve
had already eaten that fruit so either
Adam could follow God and disavow Eve or
we could follow her in sin he followed
her in sin and that's why we are doomed
okay so what doomed
Adam what doomed Adam it
was
love he
loved Eve and that's why he decided that
yes I am I am yes Eve is doomed but I
love her so I must do myself as well
that's why Adam eat the fruit because he
could not stand to leave Eve he was
bonded by by his love so what is this
telling us this is telling us that
there's only one true love and that's
the love of God which is obedience to
God every other love a love for each
other is a
falsehood okay it is a lie it can only
lead us to sin and
disaster now let me ask a question
who else said
this love can only lead you to disaster
it is a disease you must deny it you
must recognize it for the disease that
it is who else said
this Virgil right
Virgil Virgil in inad remember talked
about dle how D fell in love with enas
and inas fell in love with ditto but
then the gods tell inas obey us go to go
to Italy so you may found Rome which is
your destiny and inas because he is a
Pious man abandoned his love and did his
duty so he was honored by the gods but
ditto became consumed by her love for
inas and so she committed suicide she
destroyed herself love will destroy you
love will blind you Love is Evil okay
only obedience is
good let's
continue thus the evil act the
transgression of even the forbidden
fruit was committed only when those who
did it were already evil that bad could
only come from a bad tree further the
Badness of the tree came about contr in
nature because about a fault in the will
which is against nature it certainly
could not have happened okay but only a
nature cre out of nothing could have
distorted by fault consequently although
the will derives it its existence as a
nature from its creation by God it's
falling away from its true being it's
through its creation out of nothing okay
so this this raises a very important
question for us if it is true that we
are born of sin it is also true that God
created
us then is that a contradiction god is
perfect why would God
create a flawed
sinful um person all right and the
answer is this because God created us
out of nothing we are creation out of
nothing in other words we are a failed
science
experiment we are in a science
experiment gone
wrong he created God created Adam out of
dust and he created
Eve out of Adam the Adam's Rib basically
right so he's creating us out of
nothing and this was an
experiment and
because we were created out
nothing we were born of sin so the only
path the only um Way Forward is for us
to embrace God to become more like God
by obeying him and to deny who we are
because if we were to become more of who
we are if we listened to ourselves if we
loved if we thought if we were curious
we move into our
nothingness but the more we obey God the
more we move towards Enlightenment and
salvation okay so that's a logic here
okay so he concludes that is why
humility okay humility just means
self-denial self-
negation right complete obedience forget
who you are it doesn't matter just obey
God which is the Catholic church right
okay so he so God really means the
Catholic
church this is why humility is highly
praised in the city of God and
especially enjoying on the city of God
during the time of its progage in this
world and it receives particular
emphasis in the character of Christ the
King of that City we also taught by the
Sacred Scriptures that the fault of
exaltation Pride the contrary of
humility exercise Supreme Dominion in
Christ adversary the devil okay so he's
creating a deconomy in the city of um
Rome in the city of Earth Pride triumphs
because that's the seat of of the devil
in the city of God humility triumphs
because that's the seat of Jesus this is
ass surely the great difference that
shers the two cities on which we are
speaking the one is community of Dev VA
devout man the other company of the IR
religious and each has its own Angels
attached to it in one city love of God
has been given first place in the other
love of self pride
ego will
this all this is in found in the city of
Rome but in the city of God the only
that exists is humility and love of God
okay okay any question so
far yeah
Jesus
us oh that's a great
question okay so Jesus is dead and Jesus
didn't really do anything because we're
still born of
sin right so what did God send
Jesus and the answer is to awaken us to
show us that there's something wrong and
we must correct ourselves to lend us to
show us the light but it is we who must
walk towards the light okay does that
make sense all right so we'll
conclude with this passage and this is
towards the end of
the city of God okay in the Heavenly
City then there will be freedom of
will so this is really curious because
for the entire book He's talking he's
been talking about how freedom of will
is bad because we're born of
sin right it will be one and the same
freedom in all and indivisible in the
separate individuals it will be freed
from all evil and filled with all good
enjoying unfailingly the Delight of
Eternal Joys forgetting all offenses
forgetting all punishment ments okay so
what's the logic here the logic is this
when we are on earth we are by ourselves
we are separate from God but when we but
inste of God we we have achieved reunion
with God we will have return to God we
will be the same as God God is in us and
we are in God and therefore we will be
incapable of sin and at that point we
will have complete fre freedom of will
because our will the same as
God's okay so I know that it's
hard life sucks on Earth you're getting
exploited by the landlord you're getting
raped by the landlord you're getting
killed by your neighbors who knows okay
life sucks but just focus on your
Eternal salvation focus on obedience
because when you do so you will Ascend
to Jerusalem and at that point you will
be one with God and all everything that
you suffered on Earth will be forgotten
and it will just be endless Paradise you
are making a
sacrifice so that you may be saved
you're sacrific you sacrificing yourself
so that you may be saved okay and this
is a very powerful logic because this
becomes the logic of many powerful
movements throughout human history
including that of Communism right think
about the logic here communism what is
communism communism is we work really
hard today to build a socialist Paradise
but once we build socialist par but once
we build the Socialist Paradise we have
complete freedom of will we will be one
and the same we will be indivisible from
each other we have complete freedom to
do what we please we can as Mark says we
can fish in the afternoon and weed in
the evening and discuss politics with
our friends whenever okay we will cheap
Paradise so it's the power of the city
of God not only does it provide a
framework for the Catholic Church to
assert dominion over all of Europe but
it becomes the Catalyst for
revolutionary movements throughout human
history especially communism but but but
including other movements as
well
okay all right so any
questions okay you you want to know
about more about the biography of aug
okay all right okay I I'll do so but but
but but this is the very ending of the
seity of God okay so so let's look at
the ending together and then I'll
discuss the biography of
Augustine yet it will not forget its own
Liberation nor be ungrateful to its
Liberator okay so we have escaped this
world of evil and of sin and we are with
God who our great Liberator if we
remember even its past evils as far as
intellectual knowledge is
concerned but it will utterly forget
them as far as a sense experience is
concerned okay so what this means is yes
we will remember the pain we
suffered on Earth but the pain will mean
nothing okay we we will remember what we
experience but we not remember the pain
it will be Eternal Paradise no more pain
no more suffering no more sin okay for
the highly trained physician is
acquainted with almost all diseases as
far as it can be known in theory while
he's ignorant of most of them in respect
of personal experience since he has not
suffered from them okay we will become
Godlike in our
understanding we will understand why we
suffered and then we will understand
suffering means nothing because we are
now United with God okay does that make
sense so that's the logic
of the um sea of God and Augustine all
right so now you want to know who this
guy is all
right
so there's a lot of controversy over who
he is in his biog
biography and again remember if if a
biography is written by a politician
it's going to be BS all right just so
you know he tells us that he comes from
a pretty normal family his father's a
pagan his mother Monica is a de devout
Christian and then then through his
own hard work he started to study
rhetoric in University he became a
professor of rhetoric and then when he
was converted when he saw the light when
God spoke to him when he had his
Damascus moment he um started to to S
the Bible rigorously and then he was
spotted by his talent by the church and
at 42 he was appointed uh to become the
bishop of of Hippo okay which is
Northern
Africa and he's he was in that position
until his death one thing that Augustine
is known for is the fact that he's
prolific all right prolific which mean
which meant that he wrote a lot of books
it's possible he wrote hundreds of
thousands of
pages and his two most famous are
confessions and the City of God okay
so um
most people most Scholars take his
story for what it is okay they believe
him but one one thing that you learn in
this class is to always be skeptical of
power okay so if at age
42 he's appointed the head of the church
in this region what does it tell us it
tells us that he comes from an extremely
powerful family right because one thing
that you learn learn in this class is
the way the Catholic Church grew the way
that Christian is by marry itself to
power Christianity had a very strict
hierarchy and that enabled it to be
coopted by the power
elite okay so this tells us the fact
that he was appointed Bishop that he
comes from an extremely powerful family
his his it's possible his father was a
governor a Roman governor was possible a
general okay but this is not a typical
normal middle- class family it can't be
okay does that make sense that's the
first thing second thing is he was
prolific which meant he he wrote a lot
now in our class there's also another
individual who is extremely prolific who
and who was that
person meaning meaning meaning that he
wrote a lot like way too much this
person
is Aristotle right the thing that we
said about Aristotle is he was a
sensor A propagandist for the Macedonian
uh
Empire okay he was trying to justify the
supremacy of Greek
civilization and so when he wrote he
probably didn't write anything by
himself but he had like a team of
students around him who wrote everything
for him so you you can surmise something
Augustine as Bishop he had hundreds of
scribes hundreds of priests who
basically took his theories and um
turned them in into books and that's how
he was able to be so so prolific so
think of think of of him as a professor
basically right a university Professor a
science Professor who's in charge of a
lab he doesn't actually do his own work
he has assistance for that but he's the
one directing the research and the
writing okay you can also see him as a
propagandist does that make sense right
but he's clearly a genius okay there's
no denying he is a genius
okay any more
questions okay
so even though this is all
genius it's only
because um they're an Empire and they
can uh godlight their people okay so
think so the the logic is basically like
this the logic is I push you down and
you turn around and says hey why did you
push me down and I say to you I didn't
push you down you slipped there's a
difference all right I can do that
because I'm powerful and you're not so
this is really the logic of
Empire all right Austin is really using
the logic of
Empire and he's trying to force people
to be obedient right because obedient
leads to
Salvation hey you can disobey me
you can fo around but this means you'll
burn in hell for all eternity do you
really want to take that chance most
people don't okay so uh most people
during um most at this time choose to
become passive in order to avoid sin and
this will Mark the beginning of the Dark
Ages in
Europe okay but there are many people
who choose to Rebel there are many who
believe that exploration curiosity
intuition imagination is fundamental to
Being Human if you refuse to let me be
human then I will go somewhere else so
where do they go well they go east okay
they go east to two places the first is
the um sassanian Persian
Empire but the another place they go
that's very interesting is Arabia why do
they go to Arabia because Arabia is
basically a lawless desert there's no
real Authority in the desert and there
are lots of Jewish people and Christians
who escaped Arabia in order to practice
their faith one thing that you learned
in class that you will learn in this
class or that you have learned in this
class is that people think their faith
very seriously I rather die than not
practice my faith okay so all these
people are going to the desert in order
to practice their faith why is this
important because from Arabia will come
a new religious moov called
Islam right so these are the people who
will give birth to a revolutionary new
religion called Islam that will
challenge the authority of the Catholic
Church of
Augustine okay and this is what we will
discuss next class